well for many this week's holiday was a
whole lot different
with so many stuck apart due to the
kobit 19 pandemic
but some still chose to travel and
gather together which has the potential
to cause a cobit spike in the coming
weeks
sasha loftus spoke to las vegas across
the valley tonight who shared some of
their concerns
she joins us now live with the latest
well brian arcovic 19 numbers here in
nevada are already concerning as of late
and with
people gathering this week for
thanksgiving as you said could have the
potential
to cause a spike of case numbers we
spoke with some tonight who say it's
important to take those precautions
now to keep everyone healthy in the long
run
so you have to wash your hands
continuously you have to
wear the mask it's a sentiment we've all
shared since the start of the pandemic
so i think that the middle like to take
care be mindful of the other people is
the right path
but as we head into the holidays some
lines have blurred
as many go against cdc guidelines
aaa said up to 50 million americans plan
to travel this thanksgiving
even though health officials urged
everyone to stay home
the time has come with the cases rising
as quickly as they are
that something had to be done so i
stepped up
and we're implementing these
restrictions here in nevada
we're already seeing a coronavirus spike
with a new record of
3 100 cases and 1440 hospitalizations
set wednesday alone this is the time
that you need
everybody to just reach down and i know
we've asked a lot
and i'm asking more governor sisselak
ramped up restrictions with a statewide
pause on tuesday
but said he may take stronger actions if
things don't improve in the next few
weeks
it's kind of people need to be real
careful
not being high gatherings of people
that's why
those we spoke with say it's imperative
to make sacrifices now
so we can all look forward to a safer
future
stay positive wear your mask and you
know
wash your hands and this too shall pass
now as we've reported that statewide
pause the governor implemented on
tuesday
is set to be in place for three weeks at
that point governor sislek said he will
reevaluate and decide whether it's
necessary to tighten those restrictions
or roll them back
again all depending on those numbers
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now